ein kollege gerd joachim von fallois am
ort gehört heute fraktionen was steht an
ja das wäre mir hören von rolf mützenich
dem spd-fraktionschef der hat gerade
sein statement begonnen diese woche wo
wir beratungen anstehen haben wo es
insbesondere in dieser sitzungswoche in
den ausschüssen in den politischen
beratungen um die entlastungs pakete
geht wir wollen auf den weg bringen das
neuen euro ticket also die möglichkeit
die wir bei den entlastungs paket neben
einer sprit absenkung für die drei
monate beschlossen haben kroner pflege
bonus aber insbesondere natürlich auch
jetzt auf der zielgeraden die
mindestlohn verwirklichen wollen alles
das haben wir uns in den
ausschussberatungen mit den kolleginnen
und kollegen den berichterstatterin
berichterstattern
vorgenommen in der tat werden wir auch
noch über das sogenannte sondervermögen
also den aufwuchs im grundgesetz für die
bereitstellung von mitteln für die
bündnis und landesverteidigung
versuchen abschließend zu beraten so
dass wir das dann auch in der nächsten
sitzungswoche der haushaltswoche sein
wird dann auch mit der erforderlichen
mehrheit zu beschließen
und das bringt mich noch mal dazu dass
ich auf eine aktuelle
offensichtlich entwicklung auch im
ukraine krieg noch mal eingehen kann das
zumindestens und das ist unser eindruck
auch mein eindruck
sehr hilfreich gewesen ist dass der
generalsekretär der vereinten
nationen versucht hat mit
internationalen organisationen
humanitäre möglichkeiten zu schaffen
um insbesondere verletzte soldaten aus
umkämpften gebieten zu bringen uns das
jetzt ein teil offensichtlich
ukrainischer
soldaten das stahlwerk in mario pohl
verlassen konnte und offensichtlich dann
in den nächsten hoffentlich sagen die
notwendige medizinische versorgung
bekommt und dann vielleicht auch gegen
andere kriegsgefangener ausgetauscht
wird zeigt nochmal das diplomatische
gespräche immer wieder notwendig sind
und dass das auch die breite der debatte
finde ich hier in deutschland
reflektieren muss viel dankte erste
erschaffer
zum sondervermögen ich höre schlecht
wirklich ich habe eine frage zum
sondervermögen warum sind sie damit
nicht vorangekommen in der letzten zeit
warum ist das jetzt auch heute abend
terminiert die gespräche sieht so aus
als würde so ein bisschen vor sich
hergeschoben und in der haushaltswoche
das zu beraten erscheint mir auch ein
bisschen gewagt
nun was gewagt oder nicht gewagt ist das
wäre natürlich die parlamentarischen
geschäftsführer im hinblick auf die
tagesordnung entscheidend es geht
haushalts machen wo wir auch ja bereits
andere entscheidungen in der
vergangenheit getroffen haben
auslandseinsätze et cetera arbeiter
sondervermögen hat natürlich auch eine
finanzielle wirkung so dass eine gewisse
verbindung zwischen haushalt und
zusätzliche aufnahme von krediten nicht
ganz falsch ist und dass die beratungen
sorgfältig geführt werden müssen weil
wir ja auch eine zwei drittel mehrheit
brauchen ergibt sich aus der tatsache
dass wir diese zeit die notwendig ist
auch nutzen
um dann auch zu einem belastbaren
ergebnis zu kommen
insgesamt daran dass sich die koalition
mit der opposition insbesondere mit der
cdu csu auf einen gemeinsamen kompromiss
verständigen und es gibt ja verschiedene
bestandteile auf der einen seite die 100
milliarden in die wehrverfassung zu
bringen wir haben ein
gesetz was diese sondervermögen auf den
weg bringen soll und möglicherweise auch
noch mit dem einen oder anderen inhalt
gefüllt werden muss und dann auch wie
die parlamentarische begleitung der
verausgabung der mittel erfolgt das sind
drei konkrete bestandteile der
buchsteiner
sie erlauben zu zwei themen es heißt
dass eine einigung in der koalition gibt
es zum thema mindestlohn
dennoch ist das thema wohl diese woche
nicht auf der tagesordnung können sie
mal sagen wo drin die einigung besteht
und wann das beschlossen wird das war
das erste und das zweite ist die union
hat vorgelegt einen vorschlag zur amts
ausstattung von altkanzler gerhard
schröder
wie wird die koalition damit umgehen
werden sie diesem vorschlag zustimmen
oder werden sie eigene vorstellungen
einbringen wie könnten die aussieht und
sie zum mindestlohn werden der letzten
woche einen gesetzentwurf in erster
lesung beraten
der durch das kabinett hier den
bundestag erreicht hat wir haben uns in
den fachausschüssen natürlich nochmal
genau mit diesem gesetzentwurf befasst
es gibt ja auch die möglichkeit
dass ein
zweifacher
anerkennung von minijobs dort auch eine
zusätzliche rolle spielen kann darüber
sind beratungen erfolgt aber dass der
mindestlohn in höhe von 12 euro kommt
das steht fest und das werden wir auch
so im deutschen bundestag beschließen
darüber bin ich sehr froh weil das ja
auch eine wichtige frage gerade auch für
die sozialdemokratische partei in den
koalitionsverhandlungen gewesen ist und
wir werden einen eigenständigen
vorschlag für das büro des kanzlers
gerhard schröder im haushaltsausschuss
auf den weg bringen
zum sondervermögen
sie hatten die drei bestandteile genannt
an welchem dieser drei bestandteile hakt
es denn jetzt aus der sich gerade am
meisten und was sagen sie mit blick auf
das abstimmungsverhalten
in den ampel koalitionsfraktionen
inwiefern müssen sie der sorge haben
dass sie dann auch sehr viele stimmen
von der union angewiesen sind
wir sind da die deals sozusagen womit
der unions fraktion die sich
abrechnungen also der dreh des wie sie
wissen gibt es eine einigung immer dann
wenn man sich über die einzelnen teile
in der summe entschieden hat deswegen
gibt es nicht sag ich mal 60 prozent 440
darüber die einzelnen fragen
das 100 milliarden zur verfügung
gestellt werden sollen ist klar und dass
es eben auch in seinen bestandteilen
insbesondere für die ausrüstung
ausrüstung für die soldaten aber auch
für die landes- und bündnisverteidigung
zur verfügung gestellt werden soll also
für die sicherheit insgesamt das steht
außer frage ich glaube wir müssen
natürlich insbesondere der union
deutlich machen dass wir nicht ein
abzählreim hier im deutschen bundestag
haben wenn es um die abstimmung geht
herr merz hatte ja mal die etwas
verwegen
sozusagen für die zwei-drittel-mehrheit
nur eine bestimmte zahl von abgeordnete
union zur verfügung zu stellen ich
glaube aber auch dass der
oppositionsführer mittlerweile erkannt
hat dass artikel 35 freiheit des mandats
eigentlich die gesamte cdu csu fraktion
umfasst und ihnen das deutlich zu machen
bedarf natürlich auch immer noch mal
gemeinsame aussagen von unserer seite
die kollegin die sich hinter der kamera
und herrn rittler versteckt
haben ich habe noch eine nachfrage zudem
zudem schröder zudem schröder antrat
verstehen
wann bis wann können wir damit rechnen
und können sie schon ein bisschen
genauer präziser werden wie genau der
ungefähr aussehen soll also haben sie
schon ein paar eckpunkte im kopf wird
der schärfer sein oder wollen sie sich
daneben ein bisschen zurück zurücknehmen
und sprechen sie sich auch mit den
anderen ampel fraktionen ab oder ist das
rheiner spd nein
unbedingt sprechen wir uns aber ganz
normal wie in anderen
entscheidungen hier im bundestag mit den
koalitionspartnern ab und wir werden
auch zu einem gemeinsamen vorgehen
kommen sie wissen dass es haushalts
vermerke zu den ausstattungen der
kanzler es gibt aber auch ausstattungen
für die bundestags präsidentin und auch
für ehemalige bundespräsidenten aber
hier geht es ganz konkret eben um diese
spezielle frage und das werden wir dann
in der bereinigungssitzung des
haushaltsausschusses durch einen
haushalts vermerk der gemeinsam von den
koalitionsfraktionen auf den weg
gebracht wird entscheiden wird letztlich
über den mindestlohn gesprochen 12 euro
haben sie sich angesichts der inflation
die wir haben eigentlich mal überlegt
diskutiert ob 12 euro noch ausreichen
oder ob man nicht ein bisschen mehr
drauf packen müsste also wir haben ja
ein mechanismus eingeführt dass es eine
mindestlohn kommission gibt die immer
wieder neu bewertet vor dem hintergrund
auch auf der einen seite der
tarifentwicklung aber wir müssen
natürlich auch genau und noch einmal
darauf schauen was die inflation
insgesamt für die menschen bedeutet das
betrifft dann nicht nur diejenigen die
vom mindestlohn das sind ja mehrere
millionen menschen in zukunft
profitieren werden deswegen werden wir
und das habe ich ja bereits in der
letzten woche gesagt natürlich schauen
was diese entlastungspaket die wir jetzt
endgültig demnächst hier auch im
bundestag beschließen werden an
tatsächlichen entlastungen für die
bundesbürger auch schaffen aber ja die
inflation ist hoch und wir müssen aus
meiner sicht uns in der koalition auch
noch einmal genau anschauen ob wir
zielgenau die menschen erreichen die
meistens sagen wir jetzt mal renterinnen
und rentner die über der grundrente
liegen aber unter dem mindesteinkommen
wie wir sie auch zusätzlich entlasten
können eine entlastung die sozusagen
eine art gießkannenprinzip ist wird nach
meinem dafürhalten sehr schwierig aber
das ist die aufgabe dieser koalition in
den nächsten wochen zu entscheiden wie
wir insbesondere mit den zusätzlichen
belastungen die neben der sicherheits
belastung auch durch den krieg
verursacht worden ist nicht nur aber
auch wie wir die hierzu auch regelungen
innerhalb der bundespolitik kommen
können
kollegen
gerichts
sie haben die evakuierung in mario pohl
angesprochen und ja auch positiv
bewertet vertrauen sie denn darauf dass
russland seine zusagen tatsächlich auch
umsetzt
das ist schwer weil wir haben es nun
gelungen ein privates heil für die
abgeordneten zur verfügung die
bündnisgrünen haben ja gut abgeschnitten
bei den landtagswahlen die übrigens
interessanterweise ja bisher hier keine
große rolle gespielt haben beim
statement des spd-fraktionschefs das hat
man aber häufig nach landtagswahlen denn
die bundestags wochen sind oft
pickepackevoll und hier gibt es andere
gesetzmäßigkeiten als eben in den
ländern die nacharbeiten war ja auch
gestern aber eins ist klar natürlich
wirken sich diese auswirkungen aus
düsseldorf zum beispiel auch hier auf
die ampel in berlin aus und da gibt es
hinter den kulissen natürlich viele
gespräche miteinander es gibt ja auch
den einen oder anderen vorfall bei der
fdp zum beispiel der sprecher der dann
einfach den verteidigungsausschuss
verlassen hat obwohl dort olaf scholz
auf einladung der fdp zu gast war aber
die bündnisgrünen auch sie heute in form
von britta haßelmann einer der beiden
fraktionschefin ist auf dieses thema
zunächst nicht angegangen sondern
natürlich auch das thema was in allen
fraktionen eine wichtige rolle spielt
die ukraine und die sanktionspaket
in dieser woche blicken wir alle auf die
weiteren gespräche zum sechsten
sanktionspaket ein gipfel nach dem
andern viele intensive debatten auf
europäischer ebene im g7 format
lassen uns jetzt in diesen tagen hoffen
darauf dass es zu einer verständigung
kommt zum sechsten sanktionspaket
ich bin ganz zuversichtlich denn bisher
ist klar dass nach 80 tagen dieses
angriffskriegs von putin auf die ukraine
dieses geschlossene handeln der
europäischen
gemeinschaft der g7 staaten und auch
unser entschlossenes handeln hier in
deutschland sehr sehr wichtig sind als
signal gegenüber der ukraine und im
sanktions regime gegenüber putin in
diesem zusammenhang ist sicherlich auch
von großer bedeutung dass wir hier
national in dieser woche einmal noch das
gesetzespaket zu dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien flankiert wird
durch einen aktionsplan zur energie
effizienz der neben dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien ist die frage der
energieeffizienz und der
energieeinsparung eine ganz zentrale
robert habeck wird heute einen
aktionsplan dazu vorstellen die
zementierte abhängigkeit in die uns die
letzten jahre der
energiepolitik der alten bundesregierung
gebracht haben muss gelöst werden die
abhängigkeit der fossilen energien ist
viel zu groß und deshalb ist zum einen
das gesetzespaket zum ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien was wir in der
letzten woche gemeinsam angestoßen haben
als auch der aktionsplan
energieeffizienz
den einsparung und effizienz sind
zentrale schlüsselelemente für die frage
der unabhängigkeit fossile auf den weg
gebracht wird ein zweites thema auf das
sich die aufmerksamkeit lenken möchte
ist die diskussion über die frage des
nato beitritts von schwer in finnland
wir wissen dass
gemeinsames handeln
humanitär
wirtschaftlich finanziell und auch die
unterstützung der ukraine mit waffen in
dieser situation sehr sehr notwendig ist
der bundestag hat hier klare
entscheidungen zu getroffen die
staatengemeinschaft ist sich hier sicher
und gemeinsam und wir werden jetzt in
kürze im bundestag und dann in den
weiteren beratung über den nato beitritt
von schweden und finnland diskutieren
und dieses sehr wohlwollend und positiv
begleiten in diesem zusammenhang meine
damen und herren muss man russland heute
an dem die nachrichten und berichte über
die furchtbare situation in mario pohl
und die evakuierung von soldaten gerade
angefangen hat auffordern sich an die
genfer konventionen zu halten und hier
die
verwundeten die schwerverletzten die
soldaten nach der genfer konvention
schutz und respektvoll zu behandeln
das brauchen sie und ich hoffe dass das
für den aggressor russland an dieser
stelle auch völlig klar ist die
aufforderung ist eindeutig russland muss
sich an die genfer konventionen zum
schutz der menschen halten
zu der frage der einrichtung eines
sondervermögens sind wir in der ampel
klar verständigt deshalb haben wir auch
einen gemeinsamen ampel gesetzentwurf
eingebracht der ein sondervermögen von
100 milliarden euro für die bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit des bundes
vorsieht die formulierung und der
gesetzentwurf liegen ja vor dazu gab es
auch schon eine sachverständigenanhörung
und ich hoffe dass sich die union in den
gesprächen mit uns jetzt konstruktiv
zeigt ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
die union
einwände formulieren kann im hinblick
auf die frage des ziels der bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit des bundes
dagegen kann kein mensch sein und schon
gar nicht die union mit ihrer
verantwortung die sie für die letzten 16
jahre
auch im hinblick auf die defizitäre
desaströse ausstattung der bundeswehr
trägt denn die letzten vier
verteidigungsminister innen stellte die
union und wir haben einen erheblichen
mangel in der ausstattung selbst in der
grundausstattung bei der bundeswehr das
zeigt auch nochmal der bericht der
wehrbeauftragten und ich hoffe dass die
union in ihrer breite dieser
verantwortung nachkommt dass wir hier zu
einer guten ausrüstung ausstattung der
bundeswehr und auch
einem erweiterten sicherheitsbegriff zum
beispiel im hinblick auf die
cybersicherheit und die vorkehrungen die
wir dort zu treffen haben kommt es
finden noch gespräche statt und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wenn diese gespräche
abgeschlossen sind wir in die
parlamentarischen beratung einen schritt
weiter gehen
ja meine damen und herren das geht wie
wir das brezelbacken schon ist der
nächste da nämlich unionsfraktion ist
unionsfraktionschef friedrich merz klar
das wird der bundeskanzler am donnerstag
eine regierungserklärung abgeben zum
nächsten europäischen rat wir hoffen
dass der bundeskanzler
dann bei dieser regierungserklärung
erstmalig auch etwas konkreter wird im
hinblick auf einige themen die bei
dieser ratssitzung dann stattfinden
sollen wir erwarten dass er auch zu den
initiativen etwas sagt die insbesondere
aus deutschland möglicherweise mit
frankreich zusammen bei dieser
ratssitzung vorgetragen werden und wir
werden natürlich auch eine diskussion
über den weiteren fortgang der politik
gegenüber russland und der ukraine
miteinander führen
ich bin offen gestand etwas überrascht
über die bemerkung die er gestern abend
in einer fernsehsendung gemacht hat wo
er gefragt worden ist ob er denn nun
endlich nach kiew zu reisen beabsichtigt
er hat sich dann so eingelassen wörtlich
ich werde mich nicht ein rein in eine
gruppe von leuten die für ein kurzes
rein und raus mit einem fototermin was
machen ende des zitats also ich weiß
nicht wen er mit diesen leuten gemeint
hat möglicherweise die
bundestagspräsidentin möglicherweise
drei ausschussvorsitzende die schon vor
einiger zeit die ukraine ministerin die
in der ukraine war ich kann nur sagen
diese reise begleiten wir mit großem
respekt die aussenministerin hat dort
eine wichtige reise unternommen und wir
hoffen dass der bundeskanzler nun auch
irgendwann mal sich auf den weg macht
und die ukraine besucht das wäre ein
wichtiges zeichen auch der solidarität
des bundeskanzlers der bundesrepublik
deutschland und ich muss sagen ich finde
es befremdlich dass der bundeskanzler
ausschussvorsitzende die
bundestagspräsidentin und die
außenministerin so apostrophiert wie er
das gestern abend in dieser
fernsehsendung gesagt hat zeigt aber
auch ein bisschen welche stimmung in
dieser koalition mittlerweile herrscht
und wie auch man untereinander umgehen
miteinander das ist aber ein stil den
muss der bundeskanzler mit sich selbst
und seinem kabinett ausmachen ich finde
es um es noch einmal zu sagen
befremdlich wie er da seine
kabinettskollegin und auch wir die
bundestags repräsentanten apostrophiert
wenn er das mit diesem zitat gestern
abend so macht aber das ist
offensichtlich ein teil auch seines
umgangs stils das muss er selbst
entscheiden
alexander
ja sehr geehrte damen und herren als
aller erstes mal herzlichen glückwunsch
an die cdu nordrhein westfalen an hätte
gewiss für ein herausragendes
wahlergebnis wir freuen uns auch dass
wir von seiten des bundes aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion rückenwind gebracht
haben für die wahl in nordrhein
westfalen das hat was mit der guten
aufstellung hier auch zu tun und
deswegen wollen wir diesen erfolgreichen
weg als geschlossene cdu und csu auch
weiter fortsetzen wir werden in dieser
woche auch die vorbereitenden sitzungen
für die abschließenden
haushaltsberatungen haben es wird
sitzungen die sogenannte
bereinigungssitzung des
haushaltsausschusses
auch geben wir werden dazu einen antrag
stellen dass wir die amds ausstattung
des ehemaligen bundeskanzlers gerhard
schröder der beenden das heißt seine
mitarbeiter stellen sollen entfallen und
weitere haushaltsmittel gestrichen
werden ich glaube dass es an der
höchsten zeit ist dass die privilegien
für einen unverbesserlichen putin
lobbyisten beendet werden und deswegen
werden wir sehen wie die ampel sich zu
so einem antrag dann im
haushaltsausschuss verhält ferner werden
wir in dieser woche die beratungen über
das 100 milliarden sogenannte
sondervermögen dass die sonder schulden
für die streitkräfte fortführen die
beratungen waren ja in der letzten woche
nicht zu einem ergebnis gekommen
trotzdem sie finden in guter atmosphäre
statt wir wollen die in dieser woche
weiter fortführen bleiben aber dabei
dass es eine chance auf diese 100
milliarden nur dann gibt wenn dieses
geld vollumfänglich auch den
streitkräften zur verfügung steht und
auch die zusage des bundeskanzlers mit
dem 2 prozent ziel der nato dauerhaft
eingehalten wird dazu gibt es bisher
noch keine einigung in den verhandlungen
beide themen sind an dieser stelle
noch offen es steht nach wie vor im raum
dass teile der ampel wohl diese 100
milliarden auch für andere aufgaben
verwenden wollen wir glauben das wäre
zweckentfremdet und deswegen eine lösung
gibt es dann wenn klarheit darüber
besteht dass diese 100 milliarden den
streitkräften zu fließen ob das in
dieser woche gelingt dieses ergebnis zu
erreichen ist absolut offen wir sagen
aber auch deutlich in richtung der ampel
andere ergebnisse sind nicht möglich
weil wir stehen hier an der seite der
aussagen des bundeskanzlers der sehr
deutlich in seiner rede zur zeitenwende
diese 100 milliarden den streitkräften
zugesprochen hat das war ein versprechen
an die öffentlichkeit und nur das wenn
es eingehalten wird lässt sich mit uns
dann auch im grundgesetz umsetzen das
derzeit für drei kurze fragen herr pro
krater von der ard zuerst
eine kurze frage hätte ich herr merz und
herr dobrindt zu einem thema das noch in
den parlamentarischen beratungen ist
nämlich zum mindestlohn hat sich die
union schon fest entschieden wie sie zum
thema 12 euro mindestlohn sich verhalten
wird und müsste man mit blick auf die
inflation auf die teuerung nicht
eigentlich sagen dann braucht man sogar
mehr als zwölf euro wir haben das in der
ersten lesung bereits klar gesagt
niemand von uns ist gegen 12 euro
mindestlohn im gegenteil wir sagen es
muss von 12 euro brutto mehr netto übrig
bleiben das liegt aber in der
verantwortung der regierung und wir
warten jetzt ab welche änderungen es an
diesem gesetz noch gibt sollte
ursprünglich in dieser woche auf die
tagesordnung gesetzt werden es ist
abgesetzt worden oder gar nicht erst auf
gesetzt worden und insofern warten wir
ab welche änderungen die koalition noch
vornimmt und wir werden dann die
entscheidung der fraktion treffen ob wir
zustimmen oder ablehnen wir haben
eigentlich erwartet dass dieses gesetz
in dieser woche dann im deutschen
bundestag zur abstimmung kommt
offensichtlich gibt es ja noch
erheblichen beratungsbedarf
innerhalb der ampelkoalition
zumindestens wird darüber berichtet wir
sind sehr gespannt mit welchen inhalten
der beratung sich diese ampel da gerade
auseinandersetzt und warten ab welches
ergebnis uns mitgeteilt wird es wird
dann eine intensive debatte in der
fraktion geben ich habe schon
signalisiert dass von seiten der csu
kollegen eine positive begleitung auch
dieses
mindestlohns dieser mindestlohn
entscheidung möglich ist wir würden das
gerne positiv begleiten können aber dazu
braucht es eine gemeinsamkeit in der
union und dazu natürlich auch eine
breite debatte die wir führen werden
sobald vorliegt was die ampel hier zur
abstimmung stellt dann bitte kurze
fragen herr blank noch
möglich ist vor der sommerpause
das wird an uns nicht scheitern im
gegenteil wir hatten eigentlich erwartet
dass wir schon weiter sind wir haben
unsere vorstellungen klar artikuliert
wir hören aus teilen der regierung dass
sie sich durchaus mit diesen vorschlägen
von uns anfreunden können es liegt nicht
an uns sondern es liegt an einigkeit
innerhalb der koalition wenn die
koalition einig ist können wir sehr
schnell zu ergebnissen kommen und dann
noch einen fall dem herr daneben und
dann sind wir durch
mützenich hat gerade davor die union
auch mal gewarnt so sie ihren vorschlag
war zu machen dass die stimmen aus der
unionsfraktion dann nur noch aufgefüllt
werden für die nötige
zwei-drittel-mehrheit können sie uns
dazu noch mal kurz also wenn der
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd kollege
mütze nicht davor waren das zu tun dann
scheint er eine begründete besorgnis zu
haben dass er seine eigene fraktion
nicht in vollem umfang hinter die
beschlüsse oder hinter die vorschläge
des bundeskanzlers bringt aber das ist
dann nicht meine sorge das ist dann die
sorge der spd vielen dank herr merz
vielen dank herr dobrindt dankes
interesse denn
so da ist friedrich merz schön der frage
des kollegen ausgewichen aber es gab ja
viele fragen zu dem sondervermögen das
eigentlich in dieser woche im deutschen
bundestag verabschiedet werden sollte
sondervermögen nun das ist auch ein wort
schummelei es geht natürlich um 100
milliarden schulden die aufgenommen
werden sollen für die bundeswehr da gibt
es den streit weil man die cdu csu für
eine zweidrittelmehrheit im grundgesetz
änderung braucht da gibt es den streit
und die cdu sagt unsere forderungen sind
völlig klar diese 100 milliarden müssen
komplett für die streitkräfte zur
verfügung gestellt werden die union
wollte ursprünglich dass zwei prozent
ziel für die aufrüstung der bundeswehr
pro jahr ins grundgesetz schreiben ist
jetzt schon davon abgekommen und sagt
wir wollen ein begleitgesetz und dann
will man eben die zweidrittelmehrheit
gewährleisten allerdings nur mit soviel
abgeordneten wie für die
zwei-drittel-mehrheit notwendig ist für
durch märz möchte damit erreichen dass
der bundeskanzler gezwungen ist seine
fraktion hinter sich zu bringen wie das
dann mathematisch funktionieren soll
wenn dann zwei leute krank sind et
cetera pp das ist vielleicht das
geheimnis von friedrich merz jedenfalls
wird heute abend dort weiterverhandelt
und angeblich so war ja vorhin zu hören
das dann in der kommenden woche die
allerdings eine haushaltswoche ist in 14
tagen soll es also abgestimmt werden in
der kommenden sitzungswoche und naja mal
sehen ob sich die parteien bis dahin
geeinigt haben und die fraktion so
apropos fraktionen wir machen weiter in
dem reigen und da kommen wir zur fdp die
heute nicht nur einen neuen
verteidigungspolitischen sprecher wählen
müssen nachdem herr faber sein amt zur
verfügung stellt nach den vorgängen die
ich vorhin schon mal an sprach auch vom
vergangenen freitag im
verteidigungsausschuss und deswegen ist
da eine neuwahl notwendig aber natürlich
wird auch das ergebnis ein bisschen auf
die stimmung drücken bei den liberalen
christian doerr jedenfalls der
fraktionschef dem merkte man von dem
schlechten wahlergebnissen der letzten
landtagswahlen zunächst am anfang
jedenfalls nicht viel an
selbstverständlich beschäftigen wir uns
auch in dieser sitzungswoche mit dem
fürchterlichen angriffskrieg russlands
auf die ukraine wir stellen ja fest dass
wladimir putin seine kriegsziele nicht
erreicht das hängt auch unmittelbar
damit zusammen dass der westen die
ukraine unterstützt wirtschaftlich wir
haben zahlreiche wirtschaftssanktionen
gegen russland beschlossen und
durchgesetzt auf der einen seite auf der
anderen seite natürlich auch die
wirtschaftlichen und finanziellen hilfen
für die ukraine selbst und natürlich
auch das war in der vergangenen
sitzungswoche das thema die militärische
unterstützung der ukraine insbesondere
durch die lieferung von waffen und dort
insbesondere von schweren waffen
gleichzeitig müssen wir um das dauerhaft
durchzuhalten und das hat der
bundeskanzler wie ich finde richtiger
weise erklärt in deutschland etwas
ändern einen ersten schritt den wir in
dieser woche durch den deutschen
bundestag bringen ist planungs
beschleunigung in besondere um die
unabhängigkeit von russischer energie
und gas versorgung zu gewährleisten in
der zukunft sie wissen dass wir beim
erdgas von 55% abhängigkeit von
russischem erdgas bereits auf 35 prozent
in deutschland runter sind seit beginn
dieses fürchterlichen angriffskrieges
aber die nächsten 35 prozent werden
nicht leichter werden und deswegen
arbeiten wir auf hochtouren daran dass
eben für deutschland möglich zu machen
deswegen werden wir in dieser
sitzungswoche ein gesetz durch den
deutschen bundestag bewegend zur
beschleunigten ausbau von lng terminals
in wilhelmshaven ich komme ja aus
niedersachsen das hat mich deshalb sehr
gefreut in wilhelmshaven ist ja in
erster ratschlag erfolg für ein lng
terminal und die jahre des planungs
stillstands übrigens auch bei solchen
projekten es hat ja auch in der
vergangenheit ideen beispielsweise in
stade gegeben da gab es auch private
investoren das ist von der alten
bundesregierung regelmäßig blockiert
worden da ist nichts passiert wir
schaffen jetzt den rahmen damit
deutschland schnell energie unabhängig
werden kann denn das ist unser erklärtes
ziel
ich glaube dass dieses gesetz was wir in
dieser woche durch den bundestag bringen
geradezu eine blaupause ist um die
planungs beschleunigung insgesamt in
deutschland voranzubringen wir werden
prüfen inwiefern wir das auf andere
großprojekte übertragen können zur
dekarbonisierung unseres landes aber
insbesondere auch zur digitalisierung da
stehen viele investitionen an
insbesondere privatwirtschaftliche das
wollen wir entfesseln und eben diese
investitionen in deutschland möglich
machen den zweiten punkt den nicht
ansprechen möchte ist das thema
entlastung da stehen in dieser
sitzungswoche drei pakete an die wir
ebenfalls durch den bundestag bringen
zum ersten ist es der sogenannte tank
rabatt also die senkung der steuern auf
benzin und diesel
das ist wichtig weil viele pendlerinnen
und pendler in deutschland von den nicht
nur erhöhten energiekosten zu hause
sondern eben auch an der tankstelle in
den vergangenen wochen und monaten
betroffen sind also die pendlerinnen und
pendler stehen hier im fokus und zum
anderen auch der mittelstand gerade die
handwerksbetriebe die sich erheblichen
kostensteigerungen gerade bei benzin und
diesel gegenüber sahen kleine
handwerksbetriebe die auf ihr fahrzeug
angewiesen sind um ihr geld zu
erwirtschaften und das machen wir ihnen
leichter mit diesen rabatt an der
tankstelle als zweite steht an zur
beratung insbesondere am freitag im
bundesrat das sogenannte 9 euro ticket
und deswegen möchte ich das zum anlass
nehmen hier noch einmal die bundesländer
zu bitten diesem gesetz zuzustimmen
das ist teil eines pakets das ist das
eine aber zum anderen ist es auch ein
gutes signal wie man unkompliziert und
sehr günstig den öpnv nutzen kann über
drei monate jeder ist aufgerufen das
einmal auszuprobieren und da sollte eben
auch der bundesrat den weg dafür
freimachen und der dritte punkt sein
steuerlicher wir werden das vierte
corona steuer hilfe gesetz auf den weg
bringen damit verbunden insbesondere die
dauerhafte ausweitung des verlusts rück
trages sie wissen dass in der
vergangenen wahlperiode als meine partei
hier noch in der opposition war das eine
ganz wichtige forderung der freien
demokraten war den verlust rücktritt
möglich zu machen also unternehmen die
in der vergangenheit gewinne gemacht
haben können das verrechnen mit
verlusten die jetzt in der krise
entstanden sind das ist fair
insbesondere für mittelständische
unternehmen und da sorgen wir dafür dass
betriebe und unternehmen eben besser
auch durch diese krise kommen der dritte
gesamtkomplex den ich ansprechen möchte
ist die große sorge der menschen in
deutschland vor einer steigenden
inflation die natürlich mit zusätzlichen
belastung einhergeht ich sprach von über
die energiepreise das geht natürlich
ganz genau so an der ladenkasse wir
wissen dass die preise steigen und wir
haben hier in den vergangenen wochen
bereits milliardenschwere entlastungs
pakete in kürzester zeit auf den weg
gebracht aber angesichts der weiter
steigenden inflation müssen wir sollten
wir über zusätzliche entlastung
sicherlich sprechen denn viele menschen
empfinden die steigenden preise nicht
nur bei energie sondern eben auch bei
lebensmitteln als sehr große belastung
das nehmen wir als koalition sehr ernst
die inflation ist ja wenn man den
umfragen glauben schenken darf die
größte sorge zur zeit der menschen in
deutschland und diese sorge nehmen wir
als ampel koalition insgesamt sehr ernst
in dem zusammenhang will ich eines sagen
entlastung heißt für die fdp natürlich
zuallererst der staat nimmt den menschen
weniger weg nicht derzeit mehr zuschüsse
sondern wir wollen insbesondere die
arbeitnehmerin arbeitnehmer der mitte
weiter im fokus an der stelle halten und
sie wissen dass der bundesfinanzminister
im herbst ein progression bericht
vorlegen wird der progression berichte
gibt es in deutschland ja deshalb weil
die fdp vor vielen jahren in
regierungsverantwortung dieses mal
eingeführt hat der progression bericht
legt offen inwiefern durch die inflation
ungerechtfertigt höhere steuern anfallen
und das sollten wir dann in den fokus
nehmen und entsprechend auch für
entlastungen in deutschland sorgen
christian doerr der
fdp-fraktionsvorsitzende betont sachlich
mit verschiedenen gesetzesvorhaben was
man jetzt vorhat die fdp wie gesagt
wählt einen neuen
verteidigungspolitischen sprecher und
hat sicherlich auch sonst
diskussionsbedarf nach den
landtagswahlen das hält man dann lieber
intern aber wenn die fdp schon das eine
oder andere problem hat das ist nichts
im vergleich zur afd da ist wirklich
zoff unterm dach kann man nicht anders
sagen nach dem schlechten abschneiden
bei den landtagswahlen hat johanna das
ist eine abgeordnete hier aus dem
deutschen bundestag die vor einem jahr
ebenfalls für den parteivorsitz
angetreten ist und verlorener tino
kubala frontal angegriffen mit drei
anderen hat sie gesagt in europa versagt
er kann diese partei nicht führen tino
copala seinerseits hat dann gestern bei
der pressekonferenz nach den
landtagswahlen gesagt dem sinne nach es
ist wie früher beim zelten die die sich
beschweren dass es besonders nass
erzählt dass die am vorher ein gepinkelt
so ungefähr hat er es gesagt in der tat
und direkt während dieser
pressekonferenz hat franco erneut
gekontert und geantwortet dass ein
niveaulos dieser man könne diese partei
nicht weiterführen da kann man gespannt
sein was am 17 bis 19 juni so im
sächsischen riesa los ist übrigens bei
phoenix dann auch zu erleben da ist der
parteitag das dürfte ganz munter werden
und tino köhler hat auch darauf
rekrutiert auf die pressekonferenz und
die angriffe von gestern in seinem
statement vor der fraktionssitzung
wissen sie es war eine bundes presse das
wissen sie waren sie anwesend sie waren
anwesend zu der der bundessprecher der
partei eingeladen war und der
spitzenkandidat aus nordrhein-westfalen
und dann bekommt man von der presse eine
pressemitteilung vorgelesen von zwei
vorstandskollegen die sich
despektierlich über den
bundesvorsitzenden geäußert haben und
das war eine reaktion auch eine
menschliche reaktion von meiner form von
mir aus die ich dort gewährt habe und
von daher denke ich von der art war es
ein vergleich den ich dort gestellt habe
und er war sinnbildlich und es hat ja
auch bei ihnen zumindest für erheiterung
gesorgt und das ist ja auch gerade im
politischen leben wichtig dass man auch
ein bisschen zur erheiterung beiträgt
ja also was soll ich dazu sagen es ist
gesagt worden ich kann es nachvollziehen
aber
das ganze muss man wird natürlich intern
aufgearbeitet
da gehört natürlich auch hin
formulierung
wir hatten diese diskussion natürlich
heute in der aufarbeitung im
bundesvorstand eine rege diskussion
genau da gehört es auch hin also intern
müssen wir natürlich darüber sprechen
auch in der nachwahlbefragung werden
diese fragen gestellt aber ich habe
heute schon im bundesvorstand und das
kann ich hier noch so mitteilen ganz
klar dargelegt dass es
jeder grundlage entbehrt und völlig
sinnentleert ist dem bundessprecher
für alles jetzt hier verantwortlich zu
machen wir hatten bereits wahlverluste
vor der ukraine
vor dem krieg in der ukraine
und wir standen mal den umfragen 218 bei
18,5 prozent
und dann sind wir in den umfragen sind
wir zurück gegangen und da müssen wir
doch eigentlich die messlatte anlegen
woran nicht das denn sind das
inhaltliche diskussion
liegt es daran wie wir uns präsentieren
die ich das aber auch daran welche
themen gerade oben sind drei medial sie
haben natürlich auch bei den nordrhein
westfalen wahlen mitbekommen dass dieses
inflationsthema überhaupt gar nicht
vorgekommen ist obwohl es eigentlich
jeden betrifft aber das wurde auch
medial recht wenig gespielt natürlich
zieht man da die die russen rahmen aber
letztendlich liegt es natürlich auch an
der einseitigkeit der energieversorgung
in deutschland wurde überhaupt gar nicht
thematisiert dann natürlich an der
gehörigen abwertung des euro fast 30
prozent innerhalb von drei monaten
gegenüber dem rubel das muss man sich
mal vorstellen dass obwohl russland
sanktioniert wird so schwach ist der
euro letztendlich und das führt
natürlich zu import preissteigerungen
und eben auch zu einer verteuerten
energieversorgung das ganze ist
hausgemacht von der politik aber
letztendlich sind diese fragen gar nicht
gestellt worden also
worauf ich hinaus will ist das
natürlich die themen eine ganz große
rolle spielen und diejenigen die medial
auch nach vorne gespielt werden und das
inflationsthema ein riesenthema wurde
medial eigentlich recht wenig im
gegenzug zu anderen fragen gespielt es
sind diese gut und böse schema die hier
permanent aufgerufen werden eine hyper
moralisierende politik hier
bundespolitisch als auch landespolitisch
und da konnten wir als afd da natürlich
keine akzente setzen so wie wir es
gewollt haben das ist völlig klar aber
die schuld allein dem bundessprecher
zuzuschieben das finde ich ungehörig das
finde ich
und kollegial und ich finde das auch
nicht still sich ja ganz im gegenteil
ich finde stillos wenn kritik geäußert
wird wird das intern gemacht aber
niemals extern und vor allen dingen
schon gar nicht während unserer
bundessprecher in der pressekonferenz
sitzt das finde ich ungehörig das ist
schlechter stil das habe ich heute
deutlich gemacht und auch darüber wird
noch zu sprechen sein und die beste
gelegenheit ist natürlich in vier wochen
wenn wir bundesparteitag haben wir mit
dem parteivorstand wählen da wird
natürlich gewählt ein neuer
parteivorstand und da wollen wir doch
einfach mal sehen was da rauskommt ja
und das können sie dann bei uns bei
phoenix verfolgen das dürfte tatsächlich
spannend sein jedenfalls ist die
fraktion der afg heute sicherlich mit
diesen vorgängen beschäftigt und wohl
auch gespalten in der frage
des geschmacks da kann man sicherlich
nicht streiten also dieser vergleich von
tino kanada hat der ein oder andere dann
doch seine bauchschmerzen gehabt aber es
geht tatsächlich um die ursachen es geht
um tieferes warum die ard nicht mehr die
werte holen kann wie noch vor geraumer
zeit das muss aufgearbeitet werden
vielleicht liegt es am spitzenpersonal
vielleicht liegt es an den inhalten oder
vielleicht auch daran dass eben
tatsächlich eine partei die an und für
sich das vorgehen von putin niemals
massiv niemals massiv abgelehnt hat
vielleicht ist das auch einer der gründe
weshalb ist für die afc im moment nicht
so richtig läuft auch bei der
linksfraktion und der linkspartei da
gibt es wirklich lange gesichter nach
den landtagswahlen
vorgestern in nordrhein westfalen man
hatte nicht damit gerechnet von seiten
der linken die fünf-prozent-hürde zu
überspringen aber dann bei 2 prozent das
ist bitter für die linke ihre fraktion
mit dem tag
wie heute ist der 17 nicht nur die linke
auch andere wollen diese dass der
gleichbehandlungs artikel ins
grundgesetz einfügen und damit fängt
eben erwartet ein statement an
ich will beginnen mit dem heute
besonderen tag gegen homophobie und
transphobie war eben vor dem reichstag
wo die initiative die eine entsprechende
unterschriftensammlung petition
veranstaltet heute bekannt gegeben hat
dass sie fast 100.000 unterschriften hat
es geht darum dass das grundgesetz für
alle verändert wird die chancen dafür
stehen meines erachtens besser als in
der letzten legislaturperiode
damals haben fdp grüne und linke einen
antrag eingebracht der den willen sehr
stark entspricht jetzt gibt es eine
situation wo zwei von den parteien in
regierungsverantwortung sind und auch
der vielleicht ministerpräsident in spe
aus nordrhein westfalen hat die
ausdrückliche bereitschaft erklärt
dieses thema auch im bundesrat positiv
zu begleiten für uns wäre es wichtig
dass artikel 3 im grundgesetz verändern
wird und so gleichstellung wie es die
väter und mütter des grundgesetzes
wollten wenn auch damals bei dem thema
mann frau sehr knapp wie die das wollten
dass wir das hinkriegen also ich würde
das ausdrücklich begrüßen das als erster
bemerkung als zweites würde ich sehr
gerne eine bemerkung zu der situation
in der ukraine hier in besonderer weise
mario pohl machen ich werte das als ein
sehr positives zeichen dass 264
ukrainische soldaten aus dem stahlwerk
evakuiert werden konnten
die zivilisten sind dort davor schon
alle raus und das zeigt deutlich dass
diplomatie etwas bewirken kann und ich
bin der festen überzeugung dass
diplomatie auch der weg ist wo wir alle
möglichkeiten nutzen müssen russland ist
verpflichtet die gefangenen gut zu
behandeln wenn einen gefangenenaustausch
dann zustande kommen sollte wäre das ein
wichtiger schritt und vielleicht ein
hoffnungszeichen dass es möglichst
zeitnah doch zu einem waffenstillstand
kommt dann jeder tag ohne
waffenstillstand ist ein furchtbarer tag
ein waffenstillstand ist so dringend
notwendig der andere schnitt schritt
oder die andere möglichkeit wäre
eskalation und völlig zurecht da bin ich
bei meinem dritten punkt hat der
bundeskanzler gestern vor einer
eskalation des konfliktes ausdrücklich
gewarnt und ich glaube dass seine
warnungen sehr berechtigt sind die
mehrheit der deutschen teilt diese sorge
und ich sage ausdrücklich wir als linke
teilen diese sorgen auch aber es ist
eben wichtig dass den worten auch taten
folgen auch taten der bundesregierung
ich kann mich gut erinnern und hat das
an dieser stelle auch gesagt dass olaf
scholz auch im spiegel gesagt hat es
wird keine schweren waffen geben um
eskalation zu verhindern das ist dann
jetzt zumindest beschluss mäßig anders
gekommen wenn auch deutsche debatte und
realität weit auseinander klaffen bisher
sind keine schweren waffen geliefert
wundere mich sowieso über manche
diskussion und stelle nur fest dass die
vereinigten staaten bis heute nicht etwa
ihr modernes kriegsgerät in die ukraine
geliefert haben auch dort gibt es
vielfach verbale erklärung ich wünsche
mir dass
die aussagen von olaf scholz auch mit
den konkreten handlungsweisen in
übereinstimmung sind und unterstütze
ausdrücklich diesen kurs der
zurückhaltung der innenpolitische
wettlauf wird uns in deutschland in
keinem fall helfen auch die lieferungen
von schweren waffen die deeskaliert
nicht sondern sie wird immer zu einer
eskalation führen ich möchte in einem
vierten punkt etwas sagen was auch mit
dem krieg in der ukraine
zusammenhängt wir haben heute von unicef
den bericht vorgestellt bekommen und
dieser bericht sagt uns auch ganz
deutlich dass auch aus der sicht von
unicef der krieg möglichst schnell
beendet werden muss es ist so dass
45 millionen kinder 45 millionen kinder
von mangelernährung betroffen sind 1
millionen kinder sterben jährlich an den
folgen des hungers und alle zehn
sekunden stirbt ein kind unter fünf
jahren wenn man selbst enkel in dieser
altersgruppe hat dann geht einem ein
solcher bericht in besonderer weise nahe
und ich kann
mir nur wünschen dass auch dass bei der
behandlung des krieges in der ukraine
und auch bei der pandemie beachtet wird
die unicef zahlen
müssten meines erachtens dringend
konsequenzen haben die mittel die unicef
braucht müssen eigentlich sofort
bereitgestellt werden es gibt aktuell
eine geberkonferenz nach der anderen was
waffen betrifft ich wünsche mir dass es
zeitnah eine geberkonferenz für unicef
gibt damit mehr getan wird gegen den
weltweiten hunger und gegen die folgen
des krieges des klimawandels und der
pandemie
so wird also dietmar bartsch meine damen
und herren und da war viel drin ich will
das noch mal ein bisschen für sie
sortieren was nun diese woche eigentlich
im deutschen bundestag stattfindet
zunächst gibt es am mittwoch um 15 uhr 5
eine orientierungs debatte zur
sterbehilfe vorher um 13 uhr schon die
befragung der bundesregierung in dem
fall von
bundesarbeitsminister heil und am
donnerstag schalten sie darum 8 uhr 45 1
da gibt es eine regierungserklärung des
bundeskanzlers zum europäischen rat und
wenn wir dann noch auf den freitag
schauen auch dort wieder ab 48 8 45
phoenix einschalten da geht es dann um
die verlängerung des mandats der
bundeswehr
ja und bei uns geht es jetzt weiter mit
michael sah in bonn also auch ganz
fleißig mit gehört ja auch in form von
vielen dank für diese einsicht und
übersicht für die nächsten politischen
tage und donnerstag 48
regierungserklärung bundeskanzler olaf
scholz nun auch aufgeschrieben olaf
scholz hat mit wolodimir selensky
telefoniert wird gerade berichtet
steffen hebestreit der sprecher der
bundesregierung teilt mit dass ging um
die militärische und humanitäre lage
dort